megan and sunny single-handedly change
the direction of the view and the reason
why i was sad to see you go is because i
thought
sunny and megan were the future of the
view so that's my top five greatest
co-host of all time
megan mccain getting some high praise on
carlos king's podcast
where she also reveals the only view
co-star she still talks to carlos's
other favorite sunny hostin
she's also the only cast member i still
have a relationship with for whatever
that's worth but i have like such love
for her and i respect her and like do we
talk every day no but if she were like
walking into the kitchen right now i
would like hug her and want to talk to
her for like a few hours so yeah she's a
really good person
and she didn't demonize me the way a lot
of other people did whatever that's
worth
that there feels like a bit of a shot at
the rest of the views lineup whoopi
goldberg joy behar and sarah haynes you
know this has been a really wild ride
that's been
honestly the best of times and the worst
of times in all ways on and off this
show
megan signed off the view for good last
august after five seasons revealing in
her memoir bad republican the one moment
that sealed her fate on the show if
you're a view fan you probably remember
was was when joey told me she didn't
miss me i'm talking about i'm talking
about somebody absolutely you treated me
so much when i was on maternity leave
you missed me so much you missed
fighting with me
i was going through postpartum anxiety i
had just come back from attorney leave
it was my second day back
moving on i like to weigh in yeah
okay guys hold on hold on stop everybody
stop it just was no longer worth it to
me what i was giving up personally it's
just television and i think in covet it
was the first time that i really started
thinking about my mental and emotional
health and then quite frankly i started
thinking about what my daughter was
going to see on the internet when she
was grown
and
i just thought like
i just don't think this is well women
should be treated when they come back
from maternity leave
megan's left tv behind now writing
columns for daily mail and raising her
daughter liberty in washington dc for me
i was ready to try new things and
explore a different lifestyle but i wish
the show and everyone truly all the best
and
i hope they're not too mad but i don't
care if they are
[Music]